[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today all right
today's question comes from Anie in
Florida my husband our two kids and I
live with my husband's widowed mom who
doesn't work we pay all the bills buy
Grocery and pay her house taxes she and
I don't get along 90% of the time
especially when it comes to my kids my
husband and I are not on the same page
with money and I don't have control over
the money unless he gives it to me we
have one debt left and we could pay it
off in one to two months if we work
together but there's just no urgency
from him my sanity is on the brink and
I'm tired of arguing with my husband and
being run over by my in-laws I've talked
to my husband and tried to lay
boundaries but then I'm just a control
freak quote unquote according to my
mother-in-law sometimes I just want to
leave and get my own apartment with my
kids but I don't feel like that would be
right and would make things worse I know
I shouldn't let other people control my
emotions but this is like a wound that
keeps getting cut open and salt poured
in it is getting away from my
mother-in-law going to fix things or am
I the
issue good night well I don't like that
she can't get money unless he gives it
to me no thank you I'm a control freak
according to my mother-in-law no thank
you yeah it sounds like you are just
breathing the air of Planet Gaslight
yeah so I all we can go on Annie is what
you've written here and so here's what I
would tell you um based on exactly what
you wrote and I always want to hold and
both hands there's there's there's two
sides to a story you are not the issue
yes getting away from your mother-in-law
would fix some things but the bigger
thing here is you have a husband who is
over over overbearing does not have a
partner um he is much more interested in
making sure his mommy's okay and um his
mommy's brought into all of your life
than he is being married and building a
life with you co-creating a world with
his wife so yes getting away from your
mother-in-law would for sure help and
you got to deal with your marriage got
to deal with your marriage and it sounds
like your husband has very little
interest in dealing with your marriage
and in fact when you try he um turns it
over to his mom and she lobs grenades at
you so
um Rachel there's there's this idea that
we're going to take a for lack of better
terms we're going to we're going to take
a practice separation for a few days and
it might be up to 30 days it might be
for two weeks but it is a I'm choosing
to step out because I'm not I'm becoming
somebody that I don't want to be with my
kids I'm becoming somebody I don't to be
with you right and anytime you do that
it's important to have we're going to
circle back at this time at this date at
this restaurant to talk um we're going
to bring this person with us you got to
set some guide rules but this is one of
those moments that continuing just to
stay in this sewer um somebody's going
to end up doing something that you can't
take back yep and so Annie you're not
crazy um you are not messed up here um
it sounds like you have tried to do
what's right and you are just getting
dragged under water and I think that's
one of the hardest parts of marriage
when you hear a situation like that
because for so many people I think
learning to balance how do I take care
of myself but also take care of this
relationship this lifelong relationship
that I'm in right right but taking care
of yourself is the key to then having a
healthier marriage and I think sometimes
we mix those up and think I got to just
fix my marriage fix my marriage but it's
actually getting you making sure okay
taking care of yourself in these moments
right especially well especially if this
sounds this almost sounds like this is
not good I was going to say abusive but
anytime somebody gives their wife an
allowance yeah that to me I classify it
as abusive that is controlling nonsense
Behavior right for two adults for two
adults right yeah but often in this
situation and it's usually wife playing
trying to please husband right um not
always but often it is the way I'm going
to try to fix my marriage is by by
cutting off parts of me yes so that I
can make this this thing that we're
quote unquote doing together all right
and what often people find after they've
cut all their toes off and all their
fingers off and is that oh he's just
going to keep moving he doesn't change
it yeah he's going to keep moving the
Finish Line it was never about us
healing our marriage right right it was
never about me healing and him healing
and us making this new thing it was
about he's just going to keep doing
whatever he wants to do right and you
find yourself with nothing right that's
someone to step out and the the language
I use is somebody's got to turn on the
lights turn off the music the party's
over I'm going to step out I'm going to
move into this place with my girlfriend
I'm going to move into this place with
my mother-in-law I mean with my mother
not the kids what do you I'd bring them
if you can yeah and often you learn a
lot if he doesn't fight you on it then
that tells you what you need to know
right but me and the kids we're going to
move over here for a couple of weeks and
I got to breathe because I can't have
your mother-in-law doing this I can't
have you blaming me for all this and if
he goes I'm about to lose lo my marriage
mhm and he gets quick dose of reality
then that's beautiful if he goes fine
get out of here me and my mom are that's
ex that's he's really telling you what
you need to know y right yep oh so hard
Annie thanks for I hate this for you I
hate this I hate this hate this I I
don't have a psychology and I I'm this
is a bias and I know it happens all over
the place I don't have a world and where
if I sat down with my wife and I said
hey I need
this that her first response would be
sucks to be you right I just don't live
in that world right right and so these
things break my heart that's right yes
right like hey I need you to to help
with I'm I doing that man that's tough
that's tough tough tough tough that's so
hard create your free every dollar
budget today the simplest way to budget
for your life